الأعراض متشابهة، لذا إذا
مرض طفلك، فقد يكون من الصعب معرفة
ما إذا كان مصابًا بفيروس كورونا المستجد (كوفيد-19)، أو الأنفلونزا RSV أو
السعال البارد بسبب الاحتقان، فهذه
أعراض شائعة لجميع تلك
الفيروسات الأربعة. دكتور آندي شين من مركز
رعاية صحة الأطفال في  تقول أتلانتا إن هناك
طرقًا للمساعدة في التمييز بين
الأمراض، انظر أولاً إلى مدى سرعة ظهور
الأعراض، حيث يكون الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي وكوفيد-19 أكثر
تدرجًا عادةً في بداية الأعراض
وقد يبدأ بسيلان الأنف ثم
يتطور إلى أعراض أخرى. حسنًا، كوفيد-19
هو الفيروس الحالي  مثير للقلق مع ما
يقرب من 19000 حالة دخول إلى المستشفى في
الأسبوع الماضي، بدأت مستويات الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي في
الارتفاع في الجنوب مع
زيادات طفيفة في غرب ووسط
البلاد. فقدان الشهية هو
شيء كلاسيكي نربطه بالفيروس المخلوي التنفسي ولكن
بالطبع يمكن أن يؤدي الكثير من الشهية إلى ذلك.  قد
تترافق مع الكثير من
الالتهابات الأخرى بالإضافة إلى أعراض الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي (RSV) وقد تشمل أيضًا السعال والعطس والحمى والصفير ونزلات
البرد عادةً ما تصل إلى ذروتها خلال يومين
إلى ثلاثة أيام مع السعال والتهاب الحلق
وسيلان أو انسداد الأنف والعينين المائيتين
والعطس وقد تشمل أعراض كوفيد-19 أعراض نوبات
سعال قصيرة  من الحمى وضيق
في التنفس وآلام في البطن والتعب
وأعراض الانفلونزا قد تشمل
الحمى والقشعريرة والصداع وسيلان الأنف
والغثيان والتعب إذا كان أحد الوالدين قلقا
بشأن الطفل، فهذا عادة ما
يكون مؤشرا على الحاجة إلى رعاية إضافية من أجل الصحة.
جاثر